Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory. just scenery for the public. Oswald, Ruby, Cooper, the Mafia. Keeps them guessing like some kind of parlor game. Prevents them from asking the most important question, why? Why was Kennedy killed? Who benefited?
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory。这只是给公众看的风景。奥斯瓦尔德、鲁比、库珀、黑手党。这让他们像玩某种客厅游戏一样不断猜测，从而阻止他们提出最重要的问题：为什么？肯尼迪为什么被杀？谁从中受益？
Who has the power to cover it up? Who? The organizing principle of any society, Mr. Garrison, is for war. The authority of the state over its people resides in its war powers. Kennedy wanted to end the Cold War in his second term. He wanted to call off the Moon Race, cooperate with the Soviets. He signed a treaty to ban nuclear testing. He refused to invade Cuba in 1962. He set out to withdraw from Vietnam. But all that ended on the 22nd of November, 1963. So that, Dominic, was Mr. X, played by Donald sutherland in oliver stone's jfk yeah which
谁有权掩盖真相？谁有？加里森先生，任何社会的组织原则都是为了战争。国家对其人民的权威源于其战争权力。肯尼迪想在第二个任期内结束冷战。他想取消登月竞赛，与苏联合作。他签署了禁止核试验条约。他拒绝在1962年入侵古巴。他着手从越南撤军。但这一切都在1963年11月22日结束了。多米尼克，这就是X先生，由唐纳德·萨瑟兰在奥利弗·斯通的《刺杀肯尼迪》中饰演，是的，这部电影
came out in 1991 and it's a very serious and sober documentary on the jfk assassination i mean of course it isn't is it it's an absolute melange of assassination related theories and conspiracy concoctions it is so i saw I saw JFK at the Cinematon when I was a teenager and it was actually the film that got me interested in American history. And were you convinced
于1991年上映，它是一部关于肯尼迪遇刺案的非常严肃、冷静的纪录片。我的意思是，当然不是，对吧？它绝对是一部关于刺杀相关理论和阴谋论的大杂烩。确实如此。我十几岁时在电影院看了《刺杀肯尼迪》，正是这部电影让我对美国历史产生了兴趣。你当时看的时候
when you watched it? No, I sort of knew it was controversial because I'd read articles in Empire magazine and in the newspapers about the controversies because people had criticised it.
被说服了吗？没有，我当时就知道它很有争议，因为我在《帝国》杂志和报纸上读过关于这些争议的文章，因为人们批评过它。
Historians had criticised it. I didn't really think about whether or not it was true. What I loved was the idea that the assassination opened up a kind of bigger story, which was the Cold War, the military-industrial complex, the Vietnam War, all of this stuff. Bi-services, FBI, CIA. Yeah, I loved that idea.
历史学家批评过它。我并没有真正去想它是否真实。我喜欢的是这种想法，即刺杀事件引出了一个更大的故事，那就是冷战、军工复合体、越南战争，所有这些东西。军方、联邦调查局、中央情报局。是的，我喜欢这个想法。
So I wrote an incredibly boring A-level research essay about Kennedy's domestic policies. And it was at that point that I started to doubt Oliver Stone's film, because it struck me that he hadn't been sufficiently radical to explain this vast conspiracy. Because the mafia are in it as well aren't they the mafia anti-castro exiles the cia the fbi the secret service we will talk about oliver stone's film a little bit later in this podcast but in a weird way the oliver stone film it is like a sort of the history of post-war america and microcosm isn't it because it has all these anxieties but i was about to say packed into it's not packed into because it's a sprawling incredibly long film uh we we watched it a couple of days ago
所以我写了一篇极其无聊的A-level研究论文，关于肯尼迪的国内政策。就在那时，我开始怀疑奥利弗·斯通的电影，因为我觉得他解释这个巨大阴谋的论据不够激进。因为黑手党也参与其中，不是吗？黑手党、反卡斯特罗流亡者、中央情报局、联邦调查局、特勤局。我们稍后会在播客中讨论奥利弗·斯通的电影，但奇怪的是，奥利弗·斯通的电影就像是战后美国历史的缩影，不是吗？因为它包含了所有这些焦虑。我本来想说它塞满了……它不是塞满了，因为它是一部极其漫长的电影。我们几天前
actually at home and i couldn't believe how long it was we had to divide it over multiple days because i kept falling asleep but do you think that's because your attention span has faded due to the impact of tiktok yes i spent so much time on TikTok, Tom, that I can no longer watch half an hour. Well, five minutes. Yeah, exactly. Obviously, the Stone film is merely an example of this enormous industry because the Kennedy conspiracy theory industry is, I suppose, bigger than today, even the Freemasons conspiracy theory, to mention one that we've already done. Sure. I mean, it's up there with Atlantis and indeed aliens. And aliens may feature in this episode, may they not?
在家里看了它，我简直不敢相信它有那么长。我们不得不分几天看完，因为我一直在打瞌睡。但你认为这是因为你的注意力因TikTok的影响而下降了吗？是的，汤姆，我在TikTok上花的时间太多了，以至于我连半小时都看不下去了。好吧，五分钟。是的，没错。显然，斯通的电影只是这个庞大产业的一个例子，因为肯尼迪阴谋论产业，我想，比今天的共济会阴谋论还要大，顺便提一下，我们已经做过那个话题了。当然。我的意思是，它和亚特兰蒂斯甚至外星人处于同一水平。外星人可能会出现在这一集中，不是吗？
Because today we are talking about the conspiracy theories, how credible any of them may be. And you are going to give your judgment. My verdict. Oh, my word. As a distinguished historian in modern America. What pressure. What pressure.
因为今天我们要讨论的是阴谋论，以及它们中任何一个的可信度。而你将给出你的判断。我的裁决。天哪。作为一位杰出的现代美国历史学家。压力真大。压力真大。
Never have I entered a podcast time under such enormous pressure. Sure you'll cope. So one thing I will just say before we start, I enjoyed your Donald Sutherland. He's of course Canadian. I don't know whether you tried to incorporate that in there. Yes, I did. Yeah. Very nice. Very nice. So he would say oot instead of out. That's what Canadians apparently do. Well, unless he's playing an American. Which is what he was doing, of course. Yes. Hence the complexity of the accent. It's an incredibly sophisticated accent because I'm playing a Canadian playing an American. I know that we've been getting some grief from Canadians for not doing any episodes on Canada. So this is one. This counts. So I want to do an homage to the Canadian accent to reassure all our Canadian listeners that we love and value you very, very much.
我从未在如此巨大的压力下参加过播客。我相信你能应付。在我们开始之前，我只想说一件事，我很喜欢你模仿的唐纳德·萨瑟兰。他当然是加拿大人。我不知道你是否试图在里面加入这一点。是的，我加了。非常棒。非常棒。所以他会把“out”说成“oot”。这显然是加拿大人会做的事。好吧，除非他在扮演美国人。而这正是他当时在做的。是的，所以口音很复杂。这是一种极其复杂的口音，因为我在扮演一个扮演美国人的加拿大人。我知道我们因为没有做任何关于加拿大的剧集而受到了一些加拿大人的抱怨。所以这一集算数。所以我想向加拿大口音致敬，以向我们所有的加拿大听众保证，我们非常、非常爱你们，也非常重视你们。
Oh, that is kind. All right. Let's get back to the Kennedy assassination. So we talked last time, didn't we, about the Dallas Police Department investigation, which I think we both agree was pretty thorough, actually. Yeah. They made mistakes. They obviously made one horrendous mistake in allowing jack ruby into the basement when they were bringing oswald out but i mean as we explained last time they had gone to
哦，那太好了。好吧，让我们回到肯尼迪遇刺案。我们上次讨论了达拉斯警察局的调查，我想我们都同意，那实际上相当彻底。是的。他们犯了错误。他们在把奥斯瓦尔德带出来时让杰克·鲁比进入地下室，显然犯了一个可怕的错误，但我的意思是，正如我们上次解释的那样，他们已经
tremendous efforts to try to stop that happening hadn't they yeah but otherwise they actually i think did did reasonably well and they think absolutely that they have got their man don't they so captain fritz the guy who's basically conducting the interrogation of Oswald, at two o'clock on the day after the assassination, he comes out and he speaks to a television reporter. And he says, I can tell you that this case is cinched, that this man killed the president. There's no question in my mind about it. Apparently he had a very gravelly accent. He assumes it is absolutely done. It's a done deal. But presumably it's Ruby's murder that changes that. It does in the long run. Everybody thinks it's done,
付出了巨大的努力试图阻止这种情况发生，不是吗？是的，但除此之外，我认为他们实际上做得相当不错，而且他们绝对认为他们抓住了凶手，不是吗？所以弗里茨队长，那个基本上负责审讯奥斯瓦尔德的人，在刺杀事件发生后的第二天下午两点，他出来对一位电视记者说话。他说，我可以告诉你，这个案子已经结了，这个人杀了总统。我心中毫无疑问。显然他有一种非常沙哑的口音。他认为这绝对是板上钉钉了。这是一桩铁案。但大概是鲁比的谋杀改变了这一点。从长远来看确实如此。每个人都认为已经结束了，
I would say, by the 23rd of November. So that's the day after the assassination. On the evening of the murder itself, so the 22nd, President Johnson, as he had suddenly become, spoke to J. Edgar Hoover at the FBI and said, obviously, I want you to look into this. Federal law enforcement agencies, not just the Dallas law enforcement agencies, should look into this. And the following day, so the same day that Fritz is talking to the press, Hoover sent Johnson the FBI's preliminary findings. They list all the evidence and they say, yeah, we completely agree with the Dallas Police Department. There's absolutely no doubt in our minds. Everything points to Lee Harvey Oswald's guilt. But as you say, the murder of Oswald by Jack Ruby changes everything. Because now Oswald cannot be put on
我想说，到11月23日。也就是刺杀事件发生的第二天。在谋杀案发生的当天晚上，也就是22日，约翰逊总统，正如他突然成为的那样，与联邦调查局的J·埃德加·胡佛通了话，说，显然，我希望你调查这件事。联邦执法机构，不仅仅是达拉斯的执法机构，应该调查这件事。第二天，也就是弗里茨对媒体讲话的同一天，胡佛向约翰逊发送了联邦调查局的初步调查结果。他们列出了所有证据，并说，是的，我们完全同意达拉斯警察局的看法。我们心中绝对没有疑问。一切都指向李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的罪行。但正如你所说，杰克·鲁比谋杀奥斯瓦尔德改变了一切。因为现在奥斯瓦尔德不能被送上
the stand. There will be no trial. There will be no resolution. It looks as if he's been silenced. Yes, exactly. Even at that point, people are already talking actually about should we have some form of resolution anyway? Because we need to put to rest public doubts. They know that there will be conspiracy theories. Well, there already are, aren't there? In Paris and London, we talked about that in the previous episode. Yes, that people are already saying, is it a conspiracy? At that point, people are saying, is it either a communist conspiracy or is it something like the Ku Klux Klan? So actually Lyndon Johnson at Love Field waiting to fly off, to be inaugurated, he had said, should we go back to Washington? Is this a communist conspiracy? I mean, that's a reasonable
证人席了。不会有审判。不会有结论。看起来他好像被灭口了。是的，完全正确。即使在那时，人们实际上已经在讨论，无论如何我们是否应该以某种形式得出结论？因为我们需要平息公众的疑虑。他们知道会有阴谋论。好吧，已经有了，不是吗？在巴黎和伦敦，我们在上一集中讨论过。是的，人们已经在说，这是一个阴谋吗？在那时，人们在说，这要么是一个共产主义阴谋，要么是像三K党那样的组织？所以实际上林登·约翰逊在爱田机场等待起飞去宣誓就职时，曾说，我们应该回华盛顿吗？这是一个共产主义阴谋吗？我的意思是，这是一个合理的
supposition to make. So on the afternoon of the 24th, that is the day that Oswald was killed by Jack Ruby, the Dean of Yale Law School, a guy called Eugene Rostow, whose brother Walt ended up becoming Lyndon Johnson's national security advisor. Ooh, very suspicious. So the Rostows are a Russian Jewish family who become very, very fierce anti-communists. Or so they say well their fame walt rostow is famously associated with getting johnson into vietnam and being the ultra the ultra hawk on vietnam anyway that's by the by or is it eugene rostow calls um well maybe yes he calls um one of johnson's aides and he says i think we should have a presidential commission johnson gets the message hoover also thinks that
推测。所以24日下午，也就是奥斯瓦尔德被杰克·鲁比杀害的那天，耶鲁法学院院长，一个叫尤金·罗斯托的人，他的兄弟沃尔特最终成为了林登·约翰逊的国家安全顾问。哦，非常可疑。所以罗斯托一家是俄罗斯犹太家庭，后来变成了非常、非常激进的反共分子。或者他们是这么说的。好吧，他们的名声……沃尔特·罗斯托以让约翰逊卷入越南战争并成为越南问题上的超级鹰派而闻名。总之，那是题外话，或者说不是？尤金·罗斯托给……嗯，也许是的，他给约翰逊的一位助手打了电话，说，我认为我们应该成立一个总统委员会。约翰逊收到了这个消息。胡佛也认为
they should do something, have something public. Hoover, that Sunday afternoon, the 24th of November, actually calls a Johnson aide we know from kind of recordings and transcripts and so on. And he says, we should have something done so that we can, and I quote, convince the public that Oswald is the real assassin. Now, for conspiracy theorists, that is a kind of smoking gun. That is absolute evidence that Jared Gohover and the Johnson White House were plotting to implicate Oswald. Because Oswald had said, I'm a patsy.
他们应该做点什么，搞点公开的东西。胡佛在那个周日下午，11月24日，实际上给约翰逊的一位助手打了电话，我们从某种录音和文字记录中得知这一点。他说，我们应该做点什么，以便我们能够，引用他的话，“说服公众奥斯瓦尔德是真正的刺客”。现在，对于阴谋论者来说，这是一种确凿的证据。这绝对证明了J·埃德加·胡佛和约翰逊白宫正在密谋陷害奥斯瓦尔德。因为奥斯瓦尔德曾说，我是个替罪羊。
I'm a patsy. Yeah. That they're talking to frame him. Of course, there is another way of interpreting that conversation, which is that Jared Gohover genuinely thinks Lee Harvey Oswald is the assassin, that he is worried about a swirl of rumors and allegations. And he says, listen, we have to get our case out there and show the public that he was the assassin, which he was. So there are two ways that you can interpret that. One thing that they're all very worried about is the influence of the Soviet Union and the Soviet Union weaponizing the conspiracy theories. So the very next day, actually, the Soviet news agency TASS
我是个替罪羊。是的。他们正在谈论陷害他。当然，对那次谈话还有另一种解读方式，那就是J·埃德加·胡佛真心认为李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德是刺客，他担心谣言和指控四起。他说，听着，我们必须把我们的案子拿出来，向公众展示他就是刺客，事实也确实如此。所以你可以有两种方式来解读。他们都非常担心的一件事是苏联的影响，以及苏联利用阴谋论。所以就在第二天，实际上，苏联塔斯社
prints a report and it says, all the circumstances of President Kennedy's tragic death allow us to assume that this murder was planned and carried out by the ultra right-wing fascist and racist circles by those who cannot stomach any step aimed at the easing of international tensions and the improvement of Soviet-American relations. So in other words, the Russians are saying, this is America, there's a hotbed of fascism and racism in America, and this is what's claimed the life of the president. So the Soviets are interpreting it through the prism of their relationships with America. But the idea that it's the kind of right-wing racist people opposed to Kennedy's policies on civil rights, I mean, that is
发表了一篇报道，上面说，肯尼迪总统悲惨死亡的所有情况都让我们认为，这次谋杀是由极右翼法西斯和种族主义圈子策划并实施的，是由那些无法容忍任何旨在缓解国际紧张局势和改善苏美关系举措的人所为。换句话说，俄罗斯人在说，这是美国，美国是法西斯主义和种族主义的温床，这就是夺去总统生命的原因。所以苏联人是通过他们与美国的关系来解读这件事的。但认为这是那种反对肯尼迪民权政策的右翼种族主义者所为，我的意思是，那是
something that if LBJ thinks it, you can kind of understand why the Soviets would think it as well. Yes. Although it obviously plays into existing Soviet propaganda. So the Soviets, especially in the developing world, have been saying, look at the scenes in Birmingham, Alabama. Look at all this stuff. The Americans are so racist. They stand for fascism. We, however, stand for racial equality and liberation. And so you can see why this is very sensitive for American kind of Cold War hawks because it's embarrassing for them.
如果林登·约翰逊也这么想，你可以理解为什么苏联人也会这么想。是的。尽管这显然迎合了现有的苏联宣传。所以苏联人，特别是在发展中国家，一直在说，看看阿拉巴马州伯明翰的场景。看看所有这些东西。美国人是如此种族主义。他们代表法西斯主义。然而，我们代表种族平等和解放。所以你可以看出为什么这对美国冷战鹰派来说非常敏感，因为这让他们感到尴尬。
They're also very conscious that in the 19th century, in 1865, there had been all kinds of conspiracy theories about the death of Abraham Lincoln. The Washington Post on the same day, energetic steps must be taken to prevent a repetition of the dreadful era of rumor and gossip that followed the assassination of President Lincoln. So in other words, the drive to set up a presidential commission, you know, it comes from the context. They're going to do it at some point. And what Johnson does is he sets up this thing called the Warren Commission. He gets the Chief Justice of the United States at the Supreme Court, Earl Warren, to run it. He is an ultra-liberal. He is a hate figure for many people on the right. And is that deliberate? I think the head of the Supreme Court is basically the most prestigious possible person you could have running this. Can I ask you, at this point, is there an assumption that if you get the great and the good to investigate it and to issue a report, that people will accept it? That is a really good
他们也非常清楚，在19世纪，1865年，关于亚伯拉罕·林肯的死亡也有各种各样的阴谋论。《华盛顿邮报》在同一天写道，必须采取有力措施，防止林肯总统遇刺后那种可怕的谣言和流言蜚语时代重演。换句话说，成立总统委员会的动力，你知道，来自于这种背景。他们迟早会这么做。约翰逊所做的是成立了一个叫沃伦委员会的机构。他让美国最高法院首席大法官厄尔·沃伦来领导它。他是一位超级自由派。他是许多右翼人士眼中的仇恨对象。这是故意的吗？我认为最高法院院长基本上是你所能找到的负责此事的最高贵的人选。我可以问你，在这一点上，是否有一种假设，即如果你让德高望重的人来调查并发布报告，人们就会接受它？这是一个非常好的
question. I mean, in the context of the kind of the degree of paranoia that emerges over the late 60s and 70s, it seems an incredibly naive idea that you just get a Supreme Court judge to sit there. But in the context of the early 60s? So I think what's so interesting about that question is that the early 60s probably are a transitional moment in the sense that there has always been distrust of authority in American history. And we'll get onto this when we talk about conspiracy theories. So obviously, the McCarthyism of the 1950s was the idea that in government, your J. Robert Oppenheimers, to go back to one of our previous podcasts, that people like that were communist agents.
问题。我的意思是，在60年代末和70年代出现的偏执狂背景下，仅仅找一位最高法院法官坐在那里，这似乎是一个极其天真的想法。但在60年代初的背景下呢？所以我认为关于那个问题最有趣的是，60年代初可能是一个过渡时刻，因为在美国历史上一直存在对权威的不信任。当我们讨论阴谋论时，我们会谈到这一点。所以显然，1950年代的麦卡锡主义就是认为在政府中，你的J·罗伯特·奥本海默们——回到我们之前的播客之一——像那样的人是共产主义特工。
So there are lots of people who would distrust such a thing. But I think in 1963, there is enough residual confidence in institutions for them to think, you know, a critical mass of Americans will be persuaded by this. Now, in 1973, 10 years later, maybe they would be saying, oh, God, everyone distrusts government. What's the point? I mean, they would have done it anyway, but of course. But in 1963, I think there's enough of them to think, well, the great and the good. There's enough confidence in the system. So they get a whole range of Democrats and Republicans. Actually, there are more Republicans than Democrats.
所以有很多人会不信任这样的事情。但我认为在1963年，人们对机构还有足够的残余信心，让他们认为，你知道，大多数美国人会被此说服。现在，在1973年，10年后，也许他们会说，哦，天哪，每个人都不信任政府。有什么意义？我的意思是，他们无论如何都会这么做，当然。但在1963年，我认为他们中有足够多的人认为，嗯，德高望重的人。对体制还有足够的信心。所以他们找了一大批民主党人和共和党人。实际上，共和党人比民主党人多。
People from the House of Representatives like Gerald Ford. Yeah, of course, the great golfer. Ends up becoming president, of course. If you're a conspiracy theory-minded person, you would say, aha, no coincidence. And actually, if you're a conspiracy theory-minded person, distrustful of government, and you believe there is a deep state and all these things, and you would look at these names, you would look at the former president of the World Bank, John McCloy, the ultimate Washington insider, the former CIA chief, Alan Dulles, US Senator Richard Russell from Georgia, and so on and so forth, and you would say, oh, come on, you can't expect us to believe
来自众议院的人，比如杰拉尔德·福特。是的，当然，那位伟大的高尔夫球手。最终成为了总统，当然。如果你是一个阴谋论心态的人，你会说，啊哈，绝非巧合。而且实际上，如果你是一个阴谋论心态的人，不信任政府，并且你相信存在深层政府和所有这些事情，你会看这些名字，你会看世界银行前行长约翰·麦克洛伊，终极华盛顿内部人士，前中央情报局局长艾伦·杜勒斯，来自佐治亚州的美国参议员理查德·拉塞尔等等，你会说，哦，拜托，你不能指望我们相信
that these people are not implicated in the conspiracy. But Russell is very reluctant, isn't he? He kind of has to be strong-armed. Nobody really wants to do it, to be completely honest with you. They just think, God, what a massive hassle. I'll get a lot of grief. I don't want to be staring at ballistics reports for the next few months. Yeah. And it's a painful and unsettling thing to have to investigate, I imagine. I mean, lots of them must have known Kennedy personally. It is. Richard Russell, for example, he's a segregationist democratic senator, but he's also one of these people who's been in the Senate since the 14th century.
这些人没有卷入阴谋。但拉塞尔非常不情愿，不是吗？他有点被迫接受。老实说，没人真的想做这件事。他们只是觉得，天哪，真是个大麻烦。我会惹上一身骚。我不想在接下来的几个月里盯着弹道报告看。是的。而且我想，调查这件事是一件痛苦且令人不安的事情。我的意思是，他们中很多人一定亲自认识肯尼迪。确实如此。理查德·拉塞尔，例如，他是一位种族隔离主义的民主党参议员，但他也是自14世纪以来就在参议院任职的人之一。
And he is, you know, a very institutionalized kind of character. He doesn't want to do it. And Johnson actually says to him, well, I've told everyone you're doing it. It's too late. You have to do it to serve the nation. And he very grumpily says, OK, fine, I'll do it. Hoover is always a bit, you know, I mean, not ambivalent. He's actually extremely anxious about the Warren Commission because he is worried that it will embarrass the FBI, that it will come out that the FBI had been aware of Oswald and they hadn't really done enough about it. And he thinks, oh, we'll just look like idiots. And he doesn't really massively cooperate with the commission. So the commission doesn't depend on the FBI to do its work for it.
而且他，你知道，是一个非常体制化的人物。他不想做。约翰逊实际上对他说，好吧，我已经告诉所有人你要做了。太晚了。你必须为了国家去做。他非常暴躁地说，好吧，行，我做。胡佛总是有点，你知道，我的意思是，不是矛盾。他实际上对沃伦委员会感到非常焦虑，因为他担心这会让联邦调查局难堪，担心联邦调查局一直知道奥斯瓦尔德的存在，但并没有真正采取足够的行动。他想，哦，我们看起来就像白痴。而且他并没有真正大规模地与委员会合作。所以委员会并不依赖联邦调查局来为它工作。
They do their own work independently. So conspiracy theorists sometimes say the FBI were actually controlling the Warren Commission. They weren't. Hoover is very jealous of his institutional position. And so there's no way he would cooperate very enthusiastically with a different kind of organization. And they do all this work for the next year. Their report is almost 900 pages long.
他们独立完成自己的工作。所以阴谋论者有时说联邦调查局实际上在控制沃伦委员会。他们没有。胡佛非常嫉妒他的机构地位。所以他不可能非常热情地与一个不同的组织合作。他们在接下来的一年里做了所有这些工作。他们的报告有近900页长。
The supporting volumes of testimony, there's 26 volumes, Tom, 3,000 different documents, 550 witness statements. I mean, it is a monumental undertaking. So Don DeLillo, in his novel Libra about Lee Harvey Oswald and the assassination, he makes the famous comment that this is the kind of thing that James Joyce, if he'd lived to be 100 and moved to Iowa City, would have written. The point being that it contains within it a complete and total portrait of America in the late 50s and early 60s. A bit like Ulysses' portrait of Dublin. I imagine as a resource for future historians, unbelievably
支持性的证词卷，有26卷，汤姆，3000份不同的文件，550份证人陈述。我的意思是，这是一项巨大的工程。所以唐·德里罗，在他关于李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德和刺杀事件的小说《天秤座》中，他发表了著名的评论，说这就像詹姆斯·乔伊斯如果活到100岁并搬到爱荷华城会写的东西。重点是它包含了50年代末和60年代初美国的完整肖像。有点像《尤利西斯》对都柏林的描绘。我想作为未来历史学家的资源，不可思议地
useful. Yeah, absolutely, Tom. Because if you think about those 500 witnesses and people they interview, they're everybody from policemen, doctors, drifters who happened to be in the streets of Dallas that day. You know, people who worked at the Texas Book Depository, the Oswald family, government people, the people in the motorcade. I mean, just this colossal range. And the conclusion of the Warren Commission is unequivocal. The Harvey Oswald acted alone. He fired the crucial shots from the sixth floor window of the Texas Book Depository. He went on to kill the Dallas policeman J.D. Tippett. Jack Ruby acted alone in killing Oswald. They say that Ruby and Oswald were not connected in any way. No evidence, they say, can be found that Os Oswald's motive will never truly be known because he's dead. However, we can reasonably surmise that he was a loser and a loner who had a very troubled life. He'd found some sort of meaning in Marxism, and it was this that motivated him to try to cement his place in history by murdering the president. End of story.
有用。是的，绝对是，汤姆。因为如果你想想那500名证人和他们采访的人，他们是所有人，从警察、医生、那天恰好在达拉斯街头的流浪汉。你知道，在德克萨斯教科书仓库工作的人，奥斯瓦尔德一家，政府人员，车队里的人。我的意思是，这简直是巨大的范围。沃伦委员会的结论是明确的。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德单独行动。他从德克萨斯教科书仓库的六楼窗户开了关键的几枪。他随后杀死了达拉斯警察J·D·蒂皮特。杰克·鲁比单独行动杀死了奥斯瓦尔德。他们说鲁比和奥斯瓦尔德没有任何联系。他们说找不到任何证据。奥斯瓦尔德的动机永远不会真正为人所知，因为他死了。然而，我们可以合理地推测，他是一个失败者和孤独者，生活非常坎坷。他在马克思主义中找到了一些意义，正是这一点促使他试图通过谋杀总统来巩固自己在历史上的地位。故事结束。
But they would say that, wouldn't they, Dominic? Well, that is the thing. Because of course, when this comes out, there are a lot of people who distrust it. And maybe before we get into the conspiracy theories themselves, there is something about America, isn't there, Tom, that means that I think it is peculiarly vulnerable, if vulnerable is not too loaded a word, to conspiracy theories. Because, for example, distrust of government is built into America's sense of itself. Yeah, well, the Constitution and the right to bear arms. The Declaration of Independence. Yeah.
但他们会这么说，不是吗，多米尼克？嗯，这就是问题所在。因为当然，当这个报告出来时，有很多人不信任它。也许在我们进入阴谋论本身之前，关于美国有一些东西，不是吗，汤姆，这意味着我认为它特别容易受到阴谋论的影响，如果“容易受到”这个词不是太沉重的话。因为，例如，对政府的不信任是美国自我意识的一部分。是的，嗯，宪法和持枪权。独立宣言。是的。
We did a series of podcasts about the American Revolution. The American revolutionaries undoubtedly have perfectly reasonable, I'm not going to say legitimate because obviously I regard it as utter treachery. They have understandable and rational reasons for distrusting George III and being frightened about British intervention in the colonies. But Dominic, you say George III, I mean, it's not George III, is it? It's his ministers and the government. But the idea that George III is this kind of malign figure, a spider at the centre of a web coordinating things. I mean, that is a paranoid understanding of what's happening
我们做了一系列关于美国革命的播客。美国革命者无疑有完全合理的——我不会说合法的，因为显然我视其为彻底的背叛——他们有可以理解和理性的理由不信任乔治三世，并对英国干预殖民地感到恐惧。但多米尼克，你说乔治三世，我的意思是，那不是乔治三世，对吧？是他的大臣们和政府。但认为乔治三世是这种邪恶的人物，一个在网中心协调事情的蜘蛛。我的意思是，那是一种对正在发生的事情的偏执理解
that I guess does feed into American history. Yes. The idea that the people at the top are plotting against the people at the bottom. Because for a conspiracy to work, you need a Mr. Big. Yes. And George III is the Mr. Big of the Declaration of Independence, having previously not really featured in all the discourse around taxes and stuff when it was colonists versus parliament. The other thing, of course, is that we talked about in American Revolution podcasts,
我想这确实助长了美国历史。是的。认为高层的人在密谋反对底层的人。因为要让阴谋奏效，你需要一个大人物。是的。而乔治三世是《独立宣言》中的大人物，此前在所有关于税收等的讨论中，当它是殖民者对阵议会时，他并没有真正出现。另一件事，当然，是我们谈到的美国革命播客中，
there is a very rich, if that's the right word, strain of anti-Catholicism in the years leading up to the American Revolution. An idea that there is a sinister conspiracy to subvert American religion, subvert American morals, all of that sort of thing. The incorporation of Quebec, very disturbing to a lot of American colonists. And that anti-Catholicism, for example, and various conspiracy theories like it, so it might be Catholics, it might be the Freemasons, it might be Jews, it might be the East Coast elite, they run through American political history, as they do in various degrees, of course, in lots of other countries as well. But I think America is founded on a kind of conspiracy theory. Don't you think, Tom? Yeah. Just on the point that Catholics are
在美国革命前的几年里，有一种非常丰富的——如果这是正确的词——反天主教倾向。一种认为存在一个险恶的阴谋来颠覆美国宗教、颠覆美国道德等等的想法。魁北克的合并，让许多美国殖民者感到非常不安。而那种反天主教倾向，例如，以及各种类似的阴谋论，所以可能是天主教徒，可能是共济会，可能是犹太人，可能是东海岸精英，它们贯穿于美国政治历史中，当然，在许多其他国家也不同程度地存在。但我认为美国是建立在一种阴谋论之上的。你不觉得吗，汤姆？是的。仅仅就天主教徒正在
conspiring against good, honest American Protestants. I mean, that is a dog that doesn't bark in this issue, does it? Kennedy is the first Catholic president, the first Catholic mess to be celebrated in the White House follows his murder. But as far as I'm aware, the idea that it's the Vatican. I believe there are very niche conspiracy theorists who make this claim. I'm sure there are, but I mean, it wouldn't be the Vatican, would it?
密谋反对善良、诚实的美国新教徒这一点而言。我的意思是，那是一条在这个问题上不叫的狗，不是吗？肯尼迪是第一位天主教总统，白宫举行的第一场天主教弥撒是在他被谋杀后。但据我所知，认为这是梵蒂冈所为。我相信有非常小众的阴谋论者提出这种说法。我相信有，但我的意思是，那不会是梵蒂冈，对吧？
It would be, I don't know, Protestants trying to kill him or something. It would be Lambeth Palace, Archbishop of Canterbury. Yes. That doesn't actually, that wouldn't be the Vatican, would it? It would be, I don't know, Protestants trying to kill him or something. It would be Lambeth Palace, the Archbishop of Canterbury. Yes. That doesn't actually, that doesn't kick in. No, it doesn't. But of course, when Kennedy went to Dallas, people were giving out pamphlets in the streets of Dallas that said John F. Kennedy is a traitor. And when Adlai Stevenson, his ambassador to the UN, had been to Dallas, he had been jostled and jeered and attacked by people who thought he was selling out to the communists. So there is a ready audience for this kind of thing. And a year later, in 1964, a very well-known historian called Richard Hofstadter published a book called The Paranoid Style in American Politics. And it seems so perfectly timed because Hofstadter was a historian of things like populism and anti-intellectualism and the sort of status
那会是，我不知道，新教徒试图杀他之类的。那会是兰贝斯宫，坎特伯雷大主教。是的。那实际上，那不会是梵蒂冈，对吧？那会是，我不知道，新教徒试图杀他之类的。那会是兰贝斯宫，坎特伯雷大主教。是的。那实际上，那并没有起作用。不，它没有。但当然，当肯尼迪去达拉斯时，人们在达拉斯街头散发传单，上面写着约翰·F·肯尼迪是叛徒。当阿德莱·史蒂文森，他驻联合国大使，去过达拉斯时，他被那些认为他向共产主义者出卖的人推搡、嘲笑和攻击。所以这类事情有一个现成的受众。一年后，在1964年，一位非常著名的历史学家理查德·霍夫施塔特出版了一本名为《美国政治中的偏执风格》的书。这看起来时机非常完美，因为霍夫施塔特是一位研究民粹主义、反智主义以及那种地位
anxieties that drove people into having all these resentments and fears. And America in the early 60s, there's a lot of this stuff around. First of all, there's the legacy of McCarthyism. McCarthyism is only 10 years old. So people who thought they were communists at the top of government. Then there is the resistance of the South, federal intervention in the cause of civil rights. So they say an overreaching, overweening government. And then the third element is in places like California or the Southwest, you have the growth of this new kind of Barry Goldwater conservatism, libertarian conservatism, which says big government, big business, big institutions have basically eroded a lot of our freedom since the
焦虑的历史学家，这些焦虑驱使人们产生所有这些怨恨和恐惧。而在60年代初的美国，周围有很多这样的东西。首先，有麦卡锡主义的遗产。麦卡锡主义才10年。所以人们认为他们是政府高层的共产主义者。然后是南方的抵抗，联邦在民权事业上的干预。所以他们说是一个越权、傲慢的政府。第三个因素是在加利福尼亚或西南部等地，你有这种新式巴里·戈德华特保守主义、自由意志保守主义的兴起，它说大政府、大企业、大机构基本上侵蚀了我们自
1930s, since the New Deal. This is the sort of stuff that Ronald Reagan is reading in the Reader's Digest, Tom. To go back to another of our previous podcasts, we need to fight to get this freedom back. Can I just ask, when are the first conspiracy theories specifically relating to Kennedy published? Because there's no internet. Presumably people are talking about this in bars and whatever. When does it start to be published? About a month after the assassination. So the first iteration, Vincent Barclay has gone through all these conspiracy theories
1930年代，自新政以来的许多自由。这就是罗纳德·里根在《读者文摘》中读到的那种东西，汤姆。回到我们之前的另一个播客，我们需要战斗以夺回这种自由。我可以问一下，第一批专门关于肯尼迪的阴谋论是什么时候出版的？因为没有互联网。大概人们在酒吧里谈论这个，等等。它是什么时候开始出版的？刺杀事件发生后大约一个月。所以第一个版本，文森特·巴克利已经研究了所有这些阴谋论
in his book Reclaiming History. A guy called Mark Lane, he publishes it in a kind of libertarian weekly. He has an article called Defense Brief for Oswald. That's December 1963. Mark Lane then, a few years later, goes on to write a book, which is the key book in really igniting the conspiracy theory stuff called Rush to Judgment. Mark Lane is a communist.
在他的书《重申历史》中。一个叫马克·莱恩的人，他在一种自由意志主义周刊上发表了它。他有一篇名为《奥斯瓦尔德辩护状》的文章。那是1963年12月。马克·莱恩后来，几年后，写了一本书，这是真正点燃阴谋论的关键书籍，名为《仓促的审判》。马克·莱恩是一个共产主义者。
He's a very keen advocate for left-wing causes. Now you can see why he would be disposed to say, Oswald, who said he was being framed, I'm just a patsy, and is being accused of being a communist and was a communist and a Marxist, he's been set up and I really need to put this right. So Mark Lane's stuff is absolutely crucial. There are other communists. So for example, there's a guy called Thomas Buchanan, who is living in Paris, who publishes a book called Who Killed Kennedy in London in May 1964. And who does he think killed Kennedy?
他是左翼事业的非常热心的倡导者。现在你可以看出为什么他会倾向于说，奥斯瓦尔德，他说他被陷害了，我只是个替罪羊，并且被指控是共产主义者，而且他确实是共产主义者和马克思主义者，他被陷害了，我真的需要纠正这一点。所以马克·莱恩的东西绝对至关重要。还有其他共产主义者。例如，有一个叫托马斯·布坎南的人，住在巴黎，他在1964年5月在伦敦出版了一本名为《谁杀了肯尼迪》的书。他认为是谁杀了肯尼迪？
He says there are two gunmen. And I think almost all these communists or left-leaning authors tend to say, this is a right-wing conspiracy. Now, sometimes they will say within the US government, but often they will say right-wing nutters, oil men, the Ku Klux Klan, you know, cold warriors, all these people kind of working together. And what about Jim Garrison, played by Kevin Costner in JFK? Kevin Costner, yes. Kevin Costner enters the story in 1967. Now, at this point, the conspiracy theory industry is gathering momentum, and you can see why, because this is the era of Vietnam. America has now got tens and tens of thousands of young men fighting and dying in Vietnam. The whole temperature of American life has changed. Riots on campuses, riots in the cities,
他说有两个枪手。而且我认为几乎所有这些共产主义者或左倾作者往往会说，这是一个右翼阴谋。现在，有时他们会说是在美国政府内部，但通常他们会说右翼疯子、石油大亨、三K党，你知道，冷战分子，所有这些人都在某种程度上合作。那么吉姆·加里森呢，在《刺杀肯尼迪》中由凯文·科斯特纳饰演？凯文·科斯特纳，是的。凯文·科斯特纳在1967年进入故事。现在，在这一点上，阴谋论产业正在积聚势头，你可以看出原因，因为这是越南时代。美国现在有成千上万的年轻人正在越南战斗和死亡。美国生活的整个温度已经改变了。校园里的骚乱，城市里的骚乱，
the economy beginning to take a sort of turn for the worse. Johnson embattled this real, it's that classic moment in a documentary, Tom, when the music changes from kind of, please, please me. And then suddenly it's the Grateful Dead or something, you know, or Jimi Hendrix. The Doors. The Doors, exactly. We're at that moment in the story. Jim Garrison is the New Orleans district attorney. And in 1967, he says, I'm actually going to solve the case myself. And he charges this bloke called Clay Shaw, who's a local businessman and kind of philanthropist
经济开始变得有点糟糕。约翰逊陷入困境，这在纪录片中是一个经典的时刻，汤姆，当音乐从那种“请，请我”变成突然是感恩而死乐队或其他什么，你知道，或者吉米·亨德里克斯。大门乐队。大门乐队，没错。我们正处于故事的那个时刻。吉姆·加里森是新奥尔良地区检察官。在1967年，他说，我实际上要亲自解决这个案子。他指控这个叫克莱·肖的家伙，他是一位当地商人和某种慈善家
who's very well known a society figure but i think not coincidentally is gay he charges him with being part of this huge conspiracy that involves anti-castro exiles local right-wing businessmen the central intelligence agency and a kind of secret gay underworld ring of people hanging around in gay brothels and things plotting to assassinate presidents right he says this guy clay shaw is the man and subsequently almost everybody who followed the trial said it was the most appalling travesty of justice and circus the clay shaw was totally innocent and he'd been dragged into court and forced to go through this incredibly demeaning thing. The garrison just got to be in his bonnet about him.
他非常出名，是一位社会名流，但我认为并非巧合的是他是同性恋。他指控他参与了这个巨大的阴谋，涉及反卡斯特罗流亡者、当地右翼商人、中央情报局，以及一群在同性恋妓院等地闲逛、密谋刺杀总统的秘密同性恋地下团伙，对吧？他说这个叫克莱·肖的家伙就是那个人，随后几乎所有关注审判的人都说这是最令人震惊的司法滑稽剧和马戏团。克莱·肖是完全无辜的，他被拖进法庭，被迫经历这种极其羞辱的事情。加里森只是对他产生了偏见。
The jury took just an hour to acquit Clayshaw. And actually garrison then, you know, everybody wrote him off as a bit of a sort of attention seeker and an eccentric. And he would, there he would have remained had not his story come to the attention of Oliver Stone. Because actually, this is one thing that struck me about watching JFK back. JFK would not be made today because it is homophobic.
陪审团只用了一个小时就判克莱·肖无罪。实际上加里森后来，你知道，每个人都把他写成一个有点寻求关注的人和怪人。如果不是他的故事引起了奥利弗·斯通的注意，他本会一直保持那样。因为实际上，这是我重看《刺杀肯尼迪》时注意到的一件事。《刺杀肯尼迪》今天不会被拍出来，因为它是恐同的。
Actually, I was hesitating to say it's homophobic, but most people today would think it was homophobic because the idea is that rent boys, gay businessmen are all part of this conspiracy. I mean, it's pretty dodgy. Well, the idea that there are conspiracies, that high circles are conspiring to break the law and then to conceal law breaking, of course, then gets turbocharged by the Watergate conspiracy, right? I mean, this presumably is what really gives the whole industry a massive shot of adrenaline. I think two things. I think one, we mentioned Vietnam earlier. The sense the government has lied to you about Vietnam, that the government knew Vietnam wasn't going well, but it continued to throw more and more men into the kind of the more. The meat grinder. Yeah. So there's that. And then of course,
实际上，我当时犹豫要不要说它是恐同的，但大多数人今天会认为它是恐同的，因为观点是男妓、同性恋商人都是这个阴谋的一部分。我的意思是，这相当可疑。嗯，认为存在阴谋，高层圈子在密谋违法，然后掩盖违法行为，当然，后来被水门事件阴谋涡轮增压了，对吧？我的意思是，这大概就是真正给整个行业注入了大量肾上腺素的东西。我想有两件事。我想第一，我们之前提到了越南。政府在越南问题上对你撒谎的感觉，政府知道越南进展不顺利，但它继续向某种磨坊里投入更多的人。绞肉机。是的。所以有那个。然后当然，
as you say, Watergate. I mean, actually actually if you want to think about the jfk assassination conspiracies and you look at them alongside watergate you would say the lesson of watergate is that all this stuff is an absolute laughable shambles yeah because when we did our watergate podcasts the only really way the way to do that especially if you're not american so you don't have a dog in the fight it's just this ludicrous farce stupid schemes to lure people onto houseboats things go wrong i. I mean, basically, that's the implication. Things go wrong. And so, with the conspiracy theories, would it be fair to say that the key focus for conspiracy theories is the grassy knoll? Yeah, it is.
正如你所说，水门事件。我的意思是，实际上，如果你想思考肯尼迪刺杀阴谋，而你把它们与水门事件放在一起看，你会说水门事件的教训是所有这些东西都是绝对可笑的混乱。是的，因为当我们做水门事件播客时，真正做到这一点的唯一方法，特别是如果你不是美国人，所以你没有参与其中，这只是这种荒谬的闹剧，愚蠢的计划引诱人们上船，事情出错。我的意思是，基本上，这就是暗示。事情出错。所以，对于阴谋论，公平地说，阴谋论的关键焦点是格拉西诺尔（草丘）吗？是的，它是。
So, this is the place where supposedly other shooters are either joining in with Lee Harvey Oswald or are shooting Kennedy to make Oswald look guilty, even though Oswald hasn't actually done it. I mean, that kind of riffs on those two themes, really. By the mid-70s, you have the Grassy Knoll established as the focus of all the conspiracy theories. By the way, the Grassy Knoll is seconds, seconds walk, not minutes walk, seconds walk from the Texas Book Depository. Because as we said before, it's such a small space. And we know that when people people are asked where do you think the shots came from where did you hear the shots some say the texas book depository some say the grassy knoll which is right next to it so actually it's not that different but also isn't the key to people
所以，这是据说其他枪手要么加入李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，要么在射杀肯尼迪以使奥斯瓦尔德看起来有罪的地方，即使奥斯瓦尔德实际上并没有做。我的意思是，这确实在某种程度上呼应了那两个主题。到70年代中期，你已经有了作为所有阴谋论焦点的格拉西诺尔。顺便说一句，格拉西诺尔距离德克萨斯教科书仓库只有几秒钟的步行路程，不是几分钟，是几秒钟。因为正如我们之前所说，这是一个如此小的空间。我们知道，当人们被问到你认为枪声来自哪里，你在哪里听到枪声时，有些人说是德克萨斯教科书仓库，有些人说是格拉西诺尔，就在它旁边。所以实际上，它并没有那么不同。但人们
obsessing about the grassy knoll that there is video footage of it. So Abraham Zapruder's film and lots of photographs and people by a decade on from it have had time to pour over every little grainy pixel of every photo. And they come up with kind of very sinister, so a bit like Deep Throat, obviously immediately glamorizes the whole Watergate conspiracy. They have the umbrella man who actually turns out to be someone who was protesting. He's protesting at Joseph Kennedy's links to the Chamberlain government. We mentioned him. And then there's the Badge Man, the Black Dog Man, and there are three tramps, aren't there?
痴迷于格拉西诺尔的关键难道不是因为有它的视频片段吗？所以亚伯拉罕·扎普鲁德的电影和许多照片，人们在十年后有时间仔细研究每一张照片的每一个颗粒像素。他们想出了一些非常险恶的东西，所以有点像“深喉”，显然立即美化了整个水门事件阴谋。他们有“雨伞人”，结果证明是一个抗议者。他在抗议约瑟夫·肯尼迪与张伯伦政府的联系。我们提到过他。然后有“徽章人”、“黑狗人”，还有三个流浪汉，不是吗？
Yeah, the tramps who are supposedly very suspicious. I believe they are just tramps. But they look very smart. They're very well-dressed tramps. They're too well-dressed by all accounts. Yeah, because they're later rounded up, aren't they? And people have done enormous work on their shoes and stuff and said, oh, their shoes are far too unscuffed for homeless people's shoes. But with the Zapruder film, it has the moment where Kennedy's brains literally get shot out.
是的，那些被认为非常可疑的流浪汉。我相信他们只是流浪汉。但他们看起来很整洁。他们是穿着非常得体的流浪汉。据所有说法，他们穿得太好了。是的，因为他们后来被围捕了，不是吗？人们在他们的鞋子等东西上做了大量工作，说，哦，他们的鞋子对于无家可归者的鞋子来说太没有磨损了。但随着扎普鲁德的电影，它有肯尼迪的大脑被字面意义上射出的那一刻。
And it does look as though it's not coming from the rear of the head, which you would expect if it's coming from the book depository. Yeah. And also Kennedy's reaction. People said that the way he lifted up his elbows and he looked very peculiar. They look at John Connelly's reaction and they say, I mean, the trouble is you can analyse this frame by frame and you see in it what you want to see, Tom.
而且看起来子弹似乎并非来自后脑勺，如果子弹来自教科书仓库，你本应预料到会是那样。是的。还有肯尼迪的反应。人们说他抬起手肘的样子看起来非常古怪。他们观察约翰·康纳利的反应，然后说，我的意思是，问题在于你可以逐帧分析这段视频，并在其中看到你想看到的东西，汤姆。
But just to say, I do think that just looking at the Zapruder film film it does look as though the shot is coming from in front of kennedy rather than from the rear i'll just put that out there well tom is now a grassy knoll truther yeah you're a grassy knoll truther and i'm glad to hear it because i don't think we should be singing from the same hymn sheet just before we go to the break which theo has been begging us to do the final thing in the 70s that gives a massive boost to the um conspiracy stuff is the house select committee on assassination so this is a committee of the house of representatives that is convened in late 1976 the 70s post-watergate is awash with conspiracy theories and self-flagellation about abuses of power there's already been a thing called the church committee into the cia into sort of cia
但我想说的是，仅仅观察扎普鲁德影片，子弹看起来确实像是从肯尼迪前方射来的，而不是从后方，我只是提出这一点。好吧，汤姆现在成了“草丘阴谋论者”了。是的，你是个“草丘阴谋论者”，我很高兴听到这个，因为我不认为我们在去休息之前应该唱同一首赞美诗。西奥一直恳求我们休息一下。70年代最后一件给阴谋论带来巨大推动力的事情是众议院暗杀调查特别委员会，这是一个在1976年底召集的众议院委员会。水门事件后的70年代充斥着阴谋论和对滥用权力的自我鞭笞。之前已经有一个名为“丘奇委员会”的机构调查中央情报局，调查某种中央情报局
abuses and this committee meets in the late 70s, and it reports in 1979, so it's members of the House of Representatives. It's a very confusing and mixed picture. So usually when you read accounts of this, they say that there was actually a conspiracy after all. Their evidence for that is they rely on a kind of dictabelt from a Dallas motorcycle police officer. Acoustic evidence of the shots on the Dictabelt seems to suggest multiple shots, more shots, possibly fired from different directions. And so on the recommendation of their experts,
的滥用职权行为，该委员会在70年代末召开会议，并于1979年提交报告，所以这是众议院议员们的工作。这是一个非常令人困惑且复杂的局面。所以通常当你阅读关于此事的报道时，他们会说其实终究还是存在阴谋。他们对此的证据是依赖于达拉斯一名摩托车警察的录音带。录音带上的枪声声学证据似乎表明有多声枪响，更多的枪声，可能来自不同的方向。因此，根据他们专家的建议，
they said, well, maybe there were more shots, maybe there were more shooters. However, very confusingly, they said that all the possible groups that could have been part of the conspiracy, so the CIA, the kgb the mafia whatever were not complicit in it they don't think and they also say by the way the warren commission did a brilliant job we really approve of the warren commission's report we just have this
他们说，嗯，也许有更多的枪声，也许有更多的枪手。然而，非常令人困惑的是，他们说所有可能参与阴谋的团体，比如中央情报局、克格勃、黑手党等等，都没有参与其中，他们不认为有参与。而且他们还说，顺便提一下，沃伦委员会的工作做得非常出色，我们非常赞同沃伦委员会的报告，我们只是有这个
extra evidence now that extra dictabelt evidence has subsequently been debunked by other acoustic experts i mean this is as with all the forensic evidence you know you ask a different expert five years later for a channel five documentary and they give you a different answer, Tom. Yeah, well, it's very like analysts looking at photographs of this monster taken in the 1930s, then 2010, suddenly announcing they're all fake. But yeah, this is on the record that perhaps there is a conspiracy. And so that then begs the question of, well, if there is a conspiracy, who is behind it? And perhaps we should take a break now. And when we come back, Dominic, we will go through the list of potential conspirators. Brilliant.
额外的证据。那些额外的录音带证据随后被其他声学专家驳斥了。我的意思是，正如所有的法医证据一样，你知道，你五年后为第五频道纪录片询问另一位专家，他们会给你一个不同的答案，汤姆。是的，这很像分析家们看着20世纪30年代拍摄的这种怪物的照片，然后到了2010年，突然宣布它们全是伪造的。但确实，有记录表明也许存在阴谋。这就引出了一个问题：如果存在阴谋，谁是幕后黑手？也许我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，多米尼克，我们将梳理潜在阴谋者的名单。太棒了。
And I will get your opinion on each of the various range of suspects. So we will see you very soon. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history. We have finally reached the stage where Dominic is going to take us through all the potential conspirators. Even in the first half, we have listed an awful lot of various organisations who could be involved. There's a wonderful
我会听取你对各种嫌疑人的看法。所以我们很快就会回来。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com，也就是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我们终于到了多米尼克要带我们梳理所有潜在阴谋者的阶段了。即使在上半场，我们也列出了大量可能参与的各种组织。有一个精彩的
comment by Bugliosi, who we've been quoting quite a lot, who says, with at least 82 gunmen shooting at Kennedy in Dealey Plaza that day, it's remarkable that his body was sufficiently intact to make it to the autopsy table. So could we kick off with your choice of what the least likely conspiracy theory is? Because I should tell you, I have actually asked ChatGBT to nominate its selection of the least plausible conspiracy theory. So I'll be interested to see whether yours matches up with the mighty depths of AI. No pressure then. sweep of the conspiracy theories. Vincent Berglioci lists 44 different organizations, Tom, that have been accused, including the Nazis, the Teamsters, the French OAS, so the people that are trying to assassinate de Gaulle,
评论来自我们经常引用的布格里奥西，他说，那天在迪利广场至少有82名枪手向肯尼迪开枪，令人惊奇的是他的尸体竟然还能完整地送到尸检台上。那么，你能先从你认为最不可能的阴谋论开始吗？因为我应该告诉你，我实际上已经让ChatGPT提名了它认为最不可信的阴谋论。所以我很想看看你的选择是否与人工智能的强大深度相符。别有压力。横扫阴谋论。文森特·布格里奥西列出了44个不同的组织，汤姆，这些组织都被指控过，包括纳粹、卡车司机工会、法国秘密军事组织（OAS），也就是那些试图暗杀戴高乐的人，
and so on and so forth. 214 different individuals, usual suspects such as Richard Nixon and J. Edgar Hoover, but there are also more exciting figures like my fellow old Malvernian, James Jesus Angleton. I'm glad to mention him again. Abraham Zapruder. Yes, the guy who shoots the film. Conceivably, John Connolly, the governor of Texas injured in the...
等等等等。214个不同的人，通常的嫌疑人如理查德·尼克松和J·埃德加·胡佛，但也有更令人兴奋的人物，比如我的老马尔文校友，詹姆斯·耶稣·安格尔顿。我很高兴再次提到他。亚伯拉罕·扎普鲁德。是的，那个拍摄电影的人。可以想象，约翰·康纳利，在事件中受伤的德克萨斯州州长……
Who gets shot himself. He was offering himself up, I think, Tom. So what, the idea there is that he shoots himself through his chest and the bullet goes back and blows off Kennedy's head. Well, the list of gunmen, I love this, the list of gunmen. So not Lee Harvey Oswald, but Jack Ruby, Lyndon Johnson, firing from two cars well he is a texan and they couldn't fire guns in texas you would think that would be noticed
他自己也中枪了。我想他是在自投罗网，汤姆。所以，那里的想法是他自己射穿了自己的胸膛，然后子弹穿过去打掉了肯尼迪的头。好吧，枪手名单，我喜欢这个，枪手名单。所以不是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，而是杰克·鲁比、林登·约翰逊，从两辆车上开火。嗯，他是德克萨斯人，他们不能在德克萨斯开枪，你会认为那会被注意到。
and the two most interesting ones are jd tippett the policeman who later died and the driver of kennedy's car bill greer shot kennedy again i think that would have been noticed you would see that in the zapruder footage so are these these the most implausible, in your opinion? No. So the two most implausible, there's a guy called George Thompson who says that 22 shots were fired in Dealey Plaza that day and five people were killed. Five people, but none of them was John F. Kennedy.
还有两个最有趣的人是JD·蒂皮特，那个后来死去的警察，以及肯尼迪座驾的司机比尔·格里尔，再次射杀肯尼迪。我想那会被注意到的，你会在扎普鲁德的录像中看到。那么，在你看来，这些是最不可信的吗？不。所以最不可信的两个，有一个叫乔治·汤普森的人说那天在迪利广场开了22枪，五个人被杀。五个人，但其中没有一个是约翰·F·肯尼迪。
Okay. So he says, the man you see in the footage who seems to be John F. Kennedy, he is Officer Tippett. Wow. Okay, that's brilliant. He was impersonating Kennedy. So where's Kennedy? Kennedy was later seen, he says, in New York a year later at a private birthday party for the writer Truman Capote.
好吧。所以他说，你在录像中看到的那个看起来像是约翰·F·肯尼迪的人，他是蒂皮特警官。哇。好吧，这太棒了。他在冒充肯尼迪。那肯尼迪在哪里？他说，肯尼迪后来在一年后出现在纽约，参加作家杜鲁门·卡波特的私人生日派对。
Okay. And then went on to live a life maybe in the Hamptons or something in seclusion. With Elvis. Yeah, presumably. And Marilyn. So there's another, maybe in the Hamptons or something in seclusion. With Elvis. Yeah, presumably. And Marilyn. So there's another, that's not the most outlandish theory. The most outlandish theory is from a guy called Milton William Cooper. I will read you the summary.
好吧。然后继续过着生活，也许是在汉普顿或其他地方隐居。和猫王在一起。是的，大概吧。还有玛丽莲。所以还有另一个，那不是最离奇的理论。最离奇的理论来自一个叫米尔顿·威廉·库珀的人。我给你读一下摘要。
America and the world are controlled by the American Council on Foreign Relations, controlled by Henry Kissinger and David Rockefeller and so on, and the International Trilateral Commission. These people are in league with aliens who invaded the United States, established a lunar base. One of the people who did the deal was George Bush senior, who obviously was involved in the oil business, but he was also actually trafficking in drugs with the CIA. Kennedy found out about Bush, the CIA and the drugs. And he said, if you do not clean up the drug problem,
美国和世界由美国外交关系委员会控制，由亨利·基辛格和大卫·洛克菲勒等人控制，还有国际三边委员会。这些人与入侵美国并建立月球基地的外星人勾结。参与这笔交易的人之一是老乔治·布什，他显然参与了石油生意，但他也实际上在与中央情报局进行毒品交易。肯尼迪发现了布什、中央情报局和毒品的事。他说，如果你不清理毒品问题，
which is undermining the morals of our youth, I will tell the world about your deal with the aliens and the Moonbase. The Moonbase, by the way, was built in collaboration with the Soviet Union. And so Bush and his colleagues, Kissinger and so on, they were not going to give in to Kennedy's blackmail. So they arranged for the driver of his car, Bill Greer, to shoot him and Dallas and framed Oswald for the murder. That's the patsy. Yeah. Okay.
这正在破坏我们年轻人的道德，我就要把你们与外星人和月球基地的交易告诉全世界。顺便说一句，月球基地是与苏联合作建造的。所以布什和他的同事们，基辛格等人，他们不会向肯尼迪的勒索屈服。所以他们安排他的司机比尔·格里尔在达拉斯射杀他，并嫁祸给奥斯瓦尔德谋杀。那是替罪羊。是的。好吧。
So chat GPT, it nominates aliens, that it's actually the aliens who conspire to kill Kennedy. Right. And that's because they don't want Kennedy to develop the moon project and discover the alien moon base on the moon. Right. And there is one intriguing piece of circumstantial evidence that I think backs this up. Go on. Which is that Captain Fritz, the gravel voice interrogator of Lee Harvey Oswald, was actually brought up very near Roswell, where the Flying Saucer, of course, crashed in 1947.
所以ChatGPT提名了外星人，说实际上是外星人密谋杀害了肯尼迪。对。这是因为他们不想让肯尼迪发展月球计划并发现月球上的外星人基地。对。而且有一个耐人寻味的间接证据，我认为支持这一点。继续。那就是弗里茨队长，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德那个嗓音沙哑的审讯者，实际上是在罗斯威尔附近长大的，当然，飞碟就是在那里于1947年坠毁的。
Oh, that's very good. I mean, it kind of ties. Well, it's no more implausible than some of the others, Tom, I think it's fair to say. So I think probably we can park those. But Dominic, if I now, a bit like a baseball pitcher, hurl some of the conspiracies at you and you see whether you can hit them for a homer. Sure. So you've talked about this idea that the Soviet Union was behind it. Yeah.
哦，那太好了。我的意思是，它有点联系。好吧，这并不比其他一些理论更不可信，汤姆，我认为公平地说。所以我认为我们大概可以把这些放在一边。但是多米尼克，如果我现在像棒球投手一样向你投掷一些阴谋论，看看你是否能把它们打出全垒打。当然。所以你谈到了苏联是幕后黑手的想法。是的。
This is quite popular right from the beginning. Plausible? No, and also not very popular. So people who are interested in conspiracy theories about the Kennedy assassination don't like the Soviet theory because it's unsatisfying. Too geopolitical. It's too geopolitical and it doesn't satisfy your need to have a secret cabal who are controlling American politics. Right, but aside from that, is it plausible? Yes, it is plausible. I mean, countries do assassinate people, but it didn't happen. We know that the reaction in the Soviet Union, they were at pains not to be seen to take
这从一开始就很流行。可信吗？不，而且也不是很流行。所以对肯尼迪遇刺阴谋论感兴趣的人不喜欢苏联理论，因为它令人不满足。太地缘政治了。它太地缘政治了，不能满足你想要一个控制美国政治的秘密阴谋集团的需求。对，但除此之外，它可信吗？是的，它是可信的。我的意思是，国家确实会暗杀人，但那并没有发生。我们知道苏联的反应，他们极力避免被视为利用
advantage of it. But they could put up a show of public grief while secretly rubbing their hands. But we know from KGB internal files that were released in the 1990s, that the KGB themselves speculated about fascist and racist organizations in the American South. Okay, so that's what they genuinely thought. The relationship between Kennedy and Khrushchev actually isn't that bad. At the end of 1963, they're through the Cuban Missile Crisis. They have concluded the test ban treaty on nuclear tests. Kennedy's Secretary of State, Dean Rusk, an anti-communist, he told the Warren Commission,
这件事。但他们可以表现出公开的悲痛，同时私下里暗自窃喜。但我们从1990年代公布的克格勃内部文件中知道，克格勃自己猜测是美国南方的法西斯和种族主义组织所为。好吧，所以这就是他们真正想的。肯尼迪和赫鲁晓夫之间的关系其实并没有那么糟糕。1963年底，他们经历了古巴导弹危机。他们已经缔结了禁止核试验条约。肯尼迪的国务卿迪恩·腊斯克，一个反共分子，他告诉沃伦委员会，
said, I cannot see what conceivable interest the Soviet Union would have in killing President Kennedy. Because the Soviet Union leadership from Stalin onwards, but particularly after Stalin, what they really want is stability. They fear instability in the global system. They fear an attack by the Americans. Killing the American president would be a bonkers gamble. It wouldn't gain them anything because it would just mean that somebody else of the same political persuasion followed him. If they were caught, they'd be in real trouble. There could be a nuclear war. Why would they do it? What about Castro, who is Kennedy's kind of a great opponent in the Bay of Pigs and the Cuban Missile Crisis?
说，我看不出苏联杀害肯尼迪总统有什么可想而知的利益。因为苏联领导层从斯大林开始，特别是斯大林之后，他们真正想要的是稳定。他们害怕全球体系的不稳定。他们害怕美国人的攻击。杀害美国总统将是一场疯狂的赌博。这不会给他们带来任何好处，因为这意味着另一个同样政治倾向的人会接替他。如果他们被抓住，他们会有大麻烦。可能会发生核战争。他们为什么要这么做？那卡斯特罗呢，他是肯尼迪在猪湾事件和古巴导弹危机中的大对手？
Again, superficially plausible. Again, unsatisfying for genuine conspiracy theorists, because if it's just a baddie, an offshore baddie, again, that doesn't satisfy your desire to have the key that explains all history and all politics. Oswald clearly was very interested in Cuba. He's obsessed with Cuba. But US investigations, I mean, they have a vested interest in seeing if it is Cuba, of course. So they properly investigate this, do they? They properly investigate it. There's no evidence whatsoever. We know from people who were with Castro on the day, so a French journalist called Jean
同样，表面上可信。同样，对于真正的阴谋论者来说不令人满足，因为如果这只是一个坏蛋，一个海外坏蛋，那同样不能满足你想要一把解释所有历史和政治的钥匙的欲望。奥斯瓦尔德显然对古巴非常感兴趣。他痴迷于古巴。但美国调查，我的意思是，他们当然有既得利益去看看是不是古巴。所以他们对此进行了适当的调查，是吗？他们进行了适当的调查。没有任何证据。我们从那天和卡斯特罗在一起的人那里知道，比如一位叫让·丹尼尔的法国记者，
Daniel, that Castro was shocked and worried on the day of Kennedy's assassination. He was worried that he would be framed for it. National Security Agency intercepts of Cuban communications show that the Cuban leadership were actually talking to each other and saying, oh gosh, the next president will be even worse than Kennedy was. Right, because presumably they don't know much about LBJ. No, they don't at all. And Castro and his men are going around asking people, what's LBJ like? You know, will he be hard on us? And Castro was actually interviewed, Tom. This is an amazing fact. Castro was interviewed by the House Select Committee on Assassinations in the 1970s. They went to Cuba to interview him about it.
卡斯特罗在肯尼迪遇刺当天感到震惊和担忧。他担心自己会被嫁祸。美国国家安全局对古巴通讯的拦截显示，古巴领导层实际上在互相交谈，说，哦天哪，下一任总统会比肯尼迪更糟糕。对，因为大概他们对LBJ了解不多。不，他们一点也不了解。卡斯特罗和他的手下到处问人，LBJ是什么样的人？你知道，他会对我们严厉吗？而且卡斯特罗实际上接受了采访，汤姆。这是一个惊人的事实。卡斯特罗在70年代接受了众议院暗杀调查特别委员会的采访。他们去了古巴采访他这件事。
I didn't know that. That's amazing. And he said, why would we have done that? He said it would be insane. If we were caught, they would attack us and they would kill me and they would destroy our revolution. Why would we do it? So here's a twist. What if it's the Cuban exiles who are thinking exactly that? Very, very popular now. There is a woman called Sylvia Odio, who was a Cuban exile, and she claimed that in September 1963, Lee Harvey Oswald was one of three men who had come to her apartment to raise money for Cuban exiles,
我不知道。那太惊人了。他说，我们为什么要那样做？他说那将是疯狂的。如果我们被抓住，他们会攻击我们，他们会杀了我，他们会摧毁我们的革命。我们为什么要这么做？所以这里有一个转折。如果那是古巴流亡者在想同样的事情呢？现在非常非常流行。有一个叫西尔维娅·奥迪奥的女人，她是一名古巴流亡者，她声称在1963年9月，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德是三个来到她公寓为古巴流亡者筹款的人之一，
and that Oswald had said, oh, exiles don't have any guts because we should have killed Kennedy after the failure of the Bay of Pigs. One slightly weird thing about this is, of course, why would Oswald be hanging around with Cuban exiles? He hates the Cuban exiles because he loves Fidel Castro and the Cuban revolution. Now, it is true that Kennedy had not given the Bay of Pigs invasion air support and that some exiles blamed him for this. On the other hand, there are three important counterpoints to this. Number one is that after the Bay of Pigs, Kennedy went out of his way to give more aid to Cuban exile groups and to sort of butter them up a bit to show that he was still on their side. Number two is that the leaders of those exile groups, contrary to what people think, are not kind of hardened criminals
而且奥斯瓦尔德说，哦，流亡者没有胆量，因为我们应该在猪湾事件失败后杀掉肯尼迪。关于这一点，有一件稍微奇怪的事情是，当然，为什么奥斯瓦尔德会和古巴流亡者混在一起？他讨厌古巴流亡者，因为他热爱菲德尔·卡斯特罗和古巴革命。现在，肯尼迪确实没有给猪湾入侵提供空中支援，一些流亡者确实因此责怪他。另一方面，对此有三个重要的反驳点。第一点是，猪湾事件后，肯尼迪不遗余力地给古巴流亡团体提供更多援助，并稍微讨好他们，以表明他仍然站在他们一边。第二点是，那些流亡团体的领导人，与人们想象的相反，并不是那种顽固的罪犯
and plotters. They are the people who had been kicked out by Castro, who had fled Castro because of a Marxist revolution. They are the professional classes of Cuba. They are professors, intellectuals, businessmen. They are not people who are accustomed to ordering murders and arranging murders. And number three is that actually, Kennedy, by the end of his life, actually gets on better with the Cuban exiles than probably any point before. There's an example at the end of the Cuban Missile Crisis. He and Jackie had gone to Miami and done a whole big thing where they'd welcomed returning prisoners from the Bay of Pigs. There had been tens of thousands of people there who had been chanting liberty, liberty. And Kennedy had said one day, they'd given him a flag and he had said one day this flag will be returned to a free Havana and everybody had cheered and been in tears. So the idea that he is just hated is not quite right. And the other thing, of course, there's no single piece of evidence. There's no piece of evidence that proves that a Cuban XL
和阴谋家。他们是被卡斯特罗赶出来的人，因为马克思主义革命而逃离卡斯特罗的人。他们是古巴的专业阶层。他们是教授、知识分子、商人。他们不是习惯于下令谋杀和安排谋杀的人。第三点是，实际上，肯尼迪在生命尽头，与古巴流亡者的关系实际上比之前任何时候都要好。古巴导弹危机结束时有一个例子。他和杰基去了迈阿密，做了一件大事，欢迎从猪湾回来的囚犯。那里有成千上万的人在呼喊自由、自由。肯尼迪曾说有一天，他们给了他一面旗帜，他说有一天这面旗帜将回到一个自由的哈瓦那，每个人都欢呼并流下了眼泪。所以他只是被憎恨的想法并不完全正确。另一件事，当然，没有单一的证据。没有任何证据证明是古巴流亡者
did it. Right. Those are presumably the leading external agents. Yeah. What about internal agents? So probably the most popular theory is that it's the CIA, right? Yes. Kennedy, after the Bay of Pigs, had said he wanted to smash the CIA up and destroy it. To splinter it into a thousand pieces and scatter it to the winds.
干的。对。那些大概是主要的外部代理人。是的。内部代理人呢？所以最流行的理论大概是中央情报局，对吧？是的。肯尼迪在猪湾事件后曾说他想粉碎中央情报局并摧毁它。把它分裂成一千块，散布到风中。
But did he say that? It is commonly thought that he did say it. You'll see that quoted many times, but people have tried to find the source of the quotation and they've never really been able to the winds. But did he say that? It is commonly thought that he did say it. You'll see that quoted many times, but people have tried to find the source of the quotation, and they've never really been able to find it. But he doesn't need to have said it. All it needs is for the CIA to think he said it. But his relationship with the CIA is not as bad as it's thought. He didn't smash it up. He gets a new guy in to run it called John McCone, who he has lunch with, I think, once a week or something. He gets on pretty well with
但他说了吗？人们普遍认为他确实说了。你会看到那句话被引用了很多次，但人们试图找到这句话的出处，却从来没能找到。但他不需要说过。只需要中央情报局认为他说了就行。但他与中央情报局的关系并不像人们想象的那么糟糕。他没有粉碎它。他找了一个新人来管理它，叫约翰·麦科恩，我想他每周左右和他吃一次午饭。他与麦科恩相处得相当好。
McCone. Some of the CIA people are bitter about the Bay of Pigs. Some of them aren't. The CIA do have a history of being complicit in the assassinations of foreign leaders, but they have no history of intervention on American soil. Are they employing Oswald? Some people say Oswald was actually working for the CIA. Why, if Oswald is a loser, a loner, and a Marxist, would the CIA employ such a man? Unless he's just pretending to be a loser. It's a hell of a deep cover that goes back to his childhood. Well, it might be. I mean, fine, if you believe that.
一些中央情报局的人对猪湾事件感到痛苦。有些人没有。中央情报局确实有参与暗杀外国领导人的历史，但他们没有在美国本土干预的历史。他们雇佣了奥斯瓦尔德吗？有些人说奥斯瓦尔德实际上是在为中央情报局工作。如果奥斯瓦尔德是一个失败者、孤独者和马克思主义者，中央情报局为什么要雇佣这样一个人？除非他只是假装成一个失败者。这可是个深不可测的卧底，一直追溯到他的童年。好吧，可能是。我的意思是，好吧，如果你相信的话。
They're fiendishly clever, aren't they, in the CIA? Well, if you believe that. But everything we know of the CIA suggests that the CIA has many clever people working for it, but they don't have supernatural powers to suborn people from the age of five or six or something. The other issue with the CIA is why Kennedy? Because one of the reasons that we spent so much time talking about Kennedy's early life, his service in the Second World War, his time in politics and all of that, to talk about the murder victim, I think was to show, I think personally, without any shred of doubt, that there was nothing radical about Kennedy that would be a threat to the CIA's interests. He's keen on the Cold War. He doesn't like communism. He's a moderate domestically. Why would the CIA want to target him specifically? What threat does he represent to them?
他们在中央情报局里非常聪明，不是吗？好吧，如果你相信的话。但我们所知道的关于中央情报局的一切都表明，中央情报局有很多聪明人在为它工作，但他们没有超自然的力量去收买五六岁大的人。关于中央情报局的另一个问题是为什么是肯尼迪？因为我们花这么多时间谈论肯尼迪的早年生活、他在第二次世界大战中的服役、他在政治中的时光以及所有这些，来谈论受害者，我认为是为了证明，我个人认为，毫无疑问，肯尼迪没有什么激进的东西会威胁到中央情报局的利益。他热衷于冷战。他不喜欢共产主义。他在国内是个温和派。中央情报局为什么要专门针对他？他对他有什么威胁？
Maybe he'd reveal the existence of aliens in roswell i don't know that's well that this is the thing one would have to reach for implausible um explanations i would say okay well another very popular one i think it's what powers james elroy's novel american tabloid yes guy who lurks behind it is jay gahoover and the fbi and am i not right in thinking that lee harveywald's mother, two years before, had said, she'd complained to newspapers in New York, that her son was working for the FBI, and that the FBI weren't working to get him out of Russia when he was in the Soviet Union? Yeah. Bonkers. Why would the FBI, the Federal Bureau of Investigation, tasked with solving federal crimes within the United States, why would they send a
也许他会揭露罗斯威尔外星人的存在，我不知道，那是……好吧，这就是问题所在，人们不得不去寻找不可信的解释，我会说。好吧，另一个非常流行的理论，我想是詹姆斯·艾尔罗伊的小说《美国小报》所依据的，是的，潜伏在幕后的人是J·埃德加·胡佛和联邦调查局。我没记错的话，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的母亲在两年前曾向纽约的报纸抱怨说，她的儿子在为联邦调查局工作，而当他在苏联时，联邦调查局并没有努力把他从俄罗斯弄出来？是的。疯狂。为什么联邦调查局，负责解决美国境内联邦犯罪的机构，会派一个
man to Russia? It's not in their remit. They have no history of sending people undercover to foreign capitals. He's not an FBI informant. They have him under suspicion because he's been to Russia and all of that stuff. The FBI have no history, again, of assassinating American political figures. The FBI would not have worked with the CIA because they have a deep institutional rivalry with the CIA. J. Edgar Hoover is an extremely, when I say conservative, I don't just mean politically conservative. He is a cautious man who hoards information and power. But isn't it said that he hates John F. Kennedy is very unclear. He regularly meets John F. Kennedy. They work together and have done for almost three years. He has a huge file on John F. Kennedy with all of his affairs, going right back to Inga Arvad in the Second World War. Marilyn and everything.
人去俄罗斯？这不在他们的职责范围内。他们没有派人潜入外国首都的历史。他不是联邦调查局的线人。他们对他有怀疑，因为他去过俄罗斯以及所有那些事情。联邦调查局同样没有暗杀美国政治人物的历史。联邦调查局不会与中央情报局合作，因为他们与中央情报局有深刻的制度竞争。J·埃德加·胡佛是一个极其……当我说是保守派时，我不仅仅是指政治上的保守。他是一个谨慎的人，囤积信息和权力。但不是说他讨厌约翰·F·肯尼迪吗？这很不清楚。他经常会见约翰·F·肯尼迪。他们一起工作，已经有近三年了。他有关于约翰·F·肯尼迪的大量档案，包括他所有的婚外情，一直追溯到第二次世界大战时的英加·阿尔瓦德。玛丽莲和所有的一切。
Yeah. Is it plausible that if, for example, John F. Kennedy was going to move him aside at his mandatory retirement age in 1965 when Hoover turned 70. Is it plausible that Hoover would arrange for Lee Harvey Osspirited kind of people, well-educated, who are working for the FBI and the CIA, would do their boss's bidding and that none of them would ever talk to the press about it or that it wouldn't fall apart like Watergate did? To me, it seems utterly implausible. Okay, so on the principle of Cui Bono, who benefits from the assassination, one obvious person who benefits because he becomes president as a result of it is Lyndon Johnson. So what about LBJ? You mentioned that the theory that he shot JFK in the motorcade. Presumably that's an insane idea, but is there any remotest shred of
是的。如果，例如，约翰·F·肯尼迪要在1965年胡佛70岁时让他强制退休，胡佛会安排李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德……这种人，受过良好教育，为联邦调查局和中央情报局工作，会听从老板的命令，而且他们中没有人会向媒体透露这件事，或者它不会像水门事件那样崩溃？对我来说，这似乎完全不可信。好吧，那么根据“谁受益”的原则，谁从暗杀中受益，一个显而易见受益的人，因为他因此成为了总统，就是林登·约翰逊。那么LBJ呢？你提到过他在车队中射杀肯尼迪的理论。大概那是个疯狂的想法，但有任何哪怕最微小的证据表明LBJ参与了吗？我的意思是，我不得不说，在我看来，他显然非常不安、心烦意乱和震惊。但也许他是个出色的演员。我不知道。所以人们说，哦，天哪，它发生在德克萨斯州。那不是巧合。在约翰逊的家乡，他某种程度上控制着那里。约翰逊并不控制德克萨斯州。但同样，想象约翰逊花这么多时间在华盛顿，会想，哦，我要在我的家乡光天化日之下谋杀他，
evidence that LBJ was involved? I mean, I have to say that he was very clearly, it seems to me, upset and distraught and shocked. But maybe he's a brilliant actor. I don't know. So people say, oh, my goodness, it happened in Texas. That's no coincidence. In Johnson's home state, which he kind of controls, Johnson doesn't control Texas. But also, lunacy to imagine that Johnson, who spends all this time in Washington, would think, oh, I'll have him murdered in broad daylight in my home state,
这太疯狂了。
thus bringing suspicion on myself rather than maybe have him poisoned when we're having dinner in Washington. Okay. Why would Johnson do it? Why would he set up the Warren Commission to investigate it with many of his own political opponents? Some people have said, well, it's because he wanted to go into Vietnam and Kennedy didn't. The reality is much more complicated.
从而引起对自己的怀疑，而不是在我们华盛顿吃晚饭时毒死他。好吧。约翰逊为什么要这么做？他为什么要设立沃伦委员会来调查它，而委员会里有许多他自己的政治对手？有些人说，嗯，这是因为他想进入越南，而肯尼迪不想。现实要复杂得多。
And, of course, Johnson is, in lots of ways, the results of his policies are more liberal than the results of I mean, Johnson is the great society in the war on poverty. All right. But he does go in deeper into Vietnam and the idea that it's the military-industrial complex. That's what Mr. X is alleging in the passage from JFK that we began this episode with. And it's the famous quotation from Eisenhower. Oliver Stone opens the film with that. He does. He does. Why Kennedy? Why is Kennedy a threat to the military-industrial complex in a way no other president is? Because he wants to take America out of Vietnam War. Well, first of all, historians disagree about whether Kennedy would have stayed in Vietnam
当然，约翰逊在很多方面，他的政策结果比……我的意思是，约翰逊是“伟大社会”和“向贫困宣战”。好吧。但他确实更深入地介入了越南，而且这是军工复合体。这就是X先生在我们这集开头引用的《刺杀肯尼迪》片段中所指控的。这是艾森豪威尔的名言。奥利弗·斯通以那句话开场。他确实。他确实。为什么是肯尼迪？为什么肯尼迪对军工复合体的威胁是其他总统所没有的？因为他想让美国退出越南战争。好吧，首先，历史学家们对于肯尼迪是否会留在越南
or come out, because the evidence, as we talked about before, is so unclear because he's still making his mind up, actually. Kennedy has stood up to the Soviet Union in the Cuban Missile Crisis. He is supporting anti-communist forces abroad. He's not soft on communism. And the thing is, Tom, let's imagine that for some reason, the CIA, the FBI, military industrial complex, whoever it is, think that Kennedy is a sufficient threat to them. He's such a radical. I mean, they completely misread him. And they think he is so dangerous that he must be assassinated. Why do they not do that to Lyndon Johnson, who passes sweeping civil rights reforms, who passes the Great Society domestic reforms, who tilts American politics farther to
还是退出意见不一，因为证据，正如我们之前谈到的，非常不清楚，因为他实际上还在拿定主意。肯尼迪在古巴导弹危机中对抗过苏联。他支持国外的反共力量。他对共产主义并不软弱。问题是，汤姆，让我们想象一下，由于某种原因，中央情报局、联邦调查局、军工复合体，无论是谁，认为肯尼迪对他们构成了足够的威胁。他太激进了。我的意思是，他们完全误读了他。他们认为他太危险了，必须被暗杀。为什么他们不对林登·约翰逊那样做？他通过了广泛的民权改革，他通过了“伟大社会”国内改革，他将美国政治进一步向
the left. Because Dominic LBJ is behind it all, obviously. Right. In that case, fine. Why do they then not assassinate Richard Nixon? Nixon, who goes to Beijing, who goes to Moscow, who signs arms control agreements for the Soviet Union, and who does end the Vietnam War, why wouldn't you kill Nixon? And also, why wouldn't you kill Donald Trump? Trump, who has an incredibly hostile relationship with the Central Intelligence Agency and with most American institutions. Trump, who effectively withdraws from Afghanistan. Trump, who criticizes NATO. Why would these groups not move against him if they were prepared to move against Kennedy? The idea makes no sense, of course, because we know that American institutions generally do not kill politicians.
左倾。因为多米尼克，LBJ显然是幕后黑手。对。那样的话，好吧。为什么他们不暗杀理查德·尼克松？尼克松，他去了北京，去了莫斯科，他签署了苏联的军备控制协议，而且他确实结束了越南战争，你为什么不杀尼克松？还有，为什么你不杀唐纳德·特朗普？特朗普，他与中央情报局和大多数美国机构有着极其敌对的关系。特朗普，他实际上从阿富汗撤军。特朗普，他批评北约。如果这些团体准备对肯尼迪采取行动，为什么他们不对他采取行动？这个想法当然说不通，因为我们知道美国机构通常不会杀害政治家。
All right. So setting American institutions to one side,, all these kind of people. What about them? right wing businessmen have just had a bloody big tax cut on f kennedy so it's simply not in their interest to do it the clan are ultimately a very crude and unsophisticated organization first of all why would they be working with lee harvey oswald why would he be involved in any any way okay because he's a commie because he's a communist and secondly law enforcement agencies would have immediately i mean who are cracking down onlan, they would have immediately unearthed this. It's implausible that the Klan, such a shambolic, in many ways incompetent organisation, would have been able to get away with this incredibly sophisticated conspiracy. And the FBI and the Dallas Police Department and the Warren Commission and the House of
好吧。所以把美国机构放在一边，所有这些人。他们呢？右翼商人刚刚从肯尼迪那里得到了巨大的减税，所以这样做根本不符合他们的利益。三K党最终是一个非常粗鲁和不成熟的组织。首先，他们为什么要和李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德合作？他为什么要以任何方式参与其中？好吧，因为他是共产党人，因为他是共产主义者。其次，执法机构会立即……我的意思是，那些打击三K党的人，他们会立即挖掘出这一点。三K党这样一个混乱的、在许多方面无能的组织，能够逃脱这种极其复杂的阴谋，是不可信的。而且联邦调查局、达拉斯警察局、沃伦委员会和众议院
Representatives simply not notice. I mean, it beggars belief that they would do this. Okay, so one last extra government american institution is the mafia okay so the mafia is a very popular i mean almost every conspiracy theory involves the mafia doesn't it so just to give you a bit of context on the mafia because we're in the last few moments of the podcast now but i think it's important to do this the mafia in america originated in the late 19th century become supercharged in the 1920s and 1930s by prohibition. So that's the point at which it's becoming
根本没有注意到。我的意思是，他们会这样做简直令人难以置信。好吧，最后一个额外的美国政府机构是黑手党。好吧，所以黑手党是一个非常流行的……我的意思是，几乎每个阴谋论都涉及黑手党，不是吗？所以为了给你一点关于黑手党的背景，因为我们现在在播客的最后几分钟了，但我认为这样做很重要。美国的黑手党起源于19世纪末，在1920年代和1930年代因禁酒令而变得超级强大。所以那是它开始
enshrined culturally in all these films and things. And then the Mafia is in the headlines a lot in the 1950s because congressional committees are leading a big crackdown on racketeering, on corruption in the trade unions, all these kinds of things. And actually Robert Kennedy was a key figure in all this, which is
在文化上被所有这些电影和事物所铭记的时刻。然后黑手党在1950年代经常出现在头条新闻中，因为国会委员会正在领导一场针对敲诈勒索、工会腐败以及所有这些事情的大规模打击行动。实际上罗伯特·肯尼迪是这一切中的关键人物，这
one of the things that has got people excited. And then, of course, in the 70s, the great age of conspiracy theories, you have the Godfather films. So the Mafia are in people's minds. Now, it's possible, well, it's not just possible, it is well known that the Mafia loathed Robert Kennedy because as Attorney General, he was orchestrating a crackdown on organized crime. The question you have to ask yourself is, if they loathed Robert Kennedy, the Attorney General, he was orchestrating a crackdown on organised crime. The question you have to ask yourself is, if they loathed Robert Kennedy, the Attorney General, would their way of getting rid of him, or trying to blunt his investigation, be to murder his brother? To whack him, I believe is the technical term. To whack his brother, but to leave Robert Kennedy himself in post. Robert Kennedy might well have
是让人们感到兴奋的事情之一。然后，当然，在70年代，阴谋论的黄金时代，你有了《教父》电影。所以黑手党在人们的脑海中。现在，有可能，嗯，不仅仅是有可能，众所周知，黑手党厌恶罗伯特·肯尼迪，因为作为司法部长，他正在策划打击有组织犯罪。你必须问自己的是，如果他们厌恶罗伯特·肯尼迪，司法部长，他正在策划打击有组织犯罪。你必须问自己的是，如果他们厌恶罗伯特·肯尼迪，司法部长，他们摆脱他或试图削弱他调查的方法会是谋杀他的兄弟吗？“干掉他”，我相信这是专业术语。干掉他的兄弟，但让罗伯特·肯尼迪本人留在职位上。罗伯特·肯尼迪很可能
continued to be Attorney General for years. He, of course, might have become president, as he tried to do, campaigned to do, in 1968. Now, we know, again, FBI wiretaps, we know that mobsters, when they discussed the murder, were quite amused and quite gleeful that President Kennedy had died. But at no point do any of them ever say to each other yeah and we did it yeah lucky luciano's guy did it or something like this they actually at one point a big mafia chief called sam jinkana is talking one of his henchmen is talking to him and they're talking about who killed kennedy and they say it was a marxist guy a mark he was a he was a marxist and one of them jokes yeah he wasn't just a marxist he was a marxman who knew to shoot. Then actually, we also know from an FBI wiretap that at a meeting in Philadelphia of mobsters
会继续担任司法部长多年。他当然可能成为总统，正如他在1968年尝试做的那样，竞选那样做。现在，我们知道，同样，联邦调查局的窃听，我们知道暴徒们在讨论谋杀时，对肯尼迪总统去世感到相当好笑和幸灾乐祸。但在任何时候，他们中没有任何人对彼此说“是的，是我们干的，是的，卢基·卢西亚诺的人干的”或类似的话。他们实际上在某个时候，一个叫萨姆·吉安卡纳的大黑手党头目在和他的一个心腹交谈，他们在谈论是谁杀了肯尼迪，他们说那是一个马克思主义者，他是一个马克思主义者，其中一个人开玩笑说“是的，他不仅是马克思主义者，他还是个神枪手”。然后实际上，我们也从联邦调查局的窃听中知道，在费城的一次暴徒会议上
in 1962, they had joked about, wouldn't it be brilliant if somebody got rid of both of the Kennedys? And the Philadelphia mafia boss, Angelo Bruno, had actually said to everybody, he told them a story. I'm going to tell you an old Italian story. And he'd said, you know, there's a king and everyone thinks he's a terrible king, but actually, you know what? He's a good king because his son who comes afterwards is even worse. And that's what would happen to us if the Kennedys ever disappeared. Vincent Bugliosi makes the point. He says, in the mafia's history in America, it is not the Sicilian mafia. So the Sicilian mafia targets judges, local politicians, and so on, I guess, in its way.
在1962年，他们开玩笑说，如果有人能除掉两个肯尼迪，那该多好？费城黑手党老大安吉洛·布鲁诺实际上对每个人说，他给他们讲了一个故事。我要给你们讲一个古老的意大利故事。他说，你知道，有一个国王，每个人都认为他是一个糟糕的国王，但实际上，你知道吗？他是一个好国王，因为他之后的儿子更糟糕。如果我们肯尼迪消失了，那就会发生在我们身上。文森特·布格里奥西指出了这一点。他说，在黑手党在美国的历史中，它不是西西里黑手党。所以西西里黑手党针对法官、地方政治家等等，我想以它的方式。
The American mafia has always gone out of its way to avoid doing that because it doesn't want attention of the federal government. So even local officials, by and large, have been able to campaign against the mafia and to call for crackdowns on crime without then being shot by a mafia guise. And he says, are we really to believe that the mafia, which considered it too risky to kill even a police officer, would find the risk acceptable if the victim were the president of the United States?
美国黑手党一直不遗余力地避免这样做，因为它不想引起联邦政府的注意。所以即使是地方官员，大体上也能竞选反对黑手党并呼吁打击犯罪，而不会被黑手党枪杀。他说，我们真的要相信，认为连杀一名警察都太冒险的黑手党，如果受害者是美国总统，会觉得风险是可以接受的吗？
So first of all, that's that issue. The mafia has this studied, deliberate policy of not drawing attention to itself by targeting public officials? And number two, why would the mafia, which is, after all, a professional criminal organization, why would they have a hit in a public place in such a risky way? I mean, you could easily miss. And why would they involve a man like lee harvey oswald who in every respect runs completely contrary to what you would expect of a mafia hitman he's not accomplished he's not reliable he's not he doesn't even have a getaway car is it plausible actually tom that any organization with a degree of competence, the CIA, the Mafia, the Secret Service, the KGB,
所以首先，那是那个问题。黑手党有一种经过深思熟虑的、故意的政策，即不通过针对公职人员来引起注意？第二，为什么黑手党，毕竟是一个专业的犯罪组织，为什么要在一个公共场所用如此冒险的方式进行暗杀？我的意思是，你很容易失手。而且为什么要涉及像李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德这样的人，他在各方面都完全违背了你对黑手党杀手的期望？他不称职，他不可靠，他甚至没有逃跑的车。汤姆，任何有一定能力的组织，中央情报局、黑手党、特勤局、克格勃，
whoever, would have Oswald firing from the sixth floor and then allow him to walk out of the building, to get on a bus, to get off the bus, to get a taxi, to go into a cinema, to shoot a policeman. That would seem peculiar operating procedures, wouldn't it? Just on the Mafia, though, there is the figure of Jack Ruby. And I know that you said that he wasn't involved in organized crime but he's definitely organized crime adjacent i mean he's running street clubs he must be yes um and i know also that he denies that he was part of any conspiracy but then he would have done wouldn't he of all these organizations jack ruby seems to be closest
无论谁，会让奥斯瓦尔德从六楼开火，然后允许他走出大楼，坐上公共汽车，下车，打车，走进电影院，射杀一名警察，这可信吗？那看起来会是奇怪的操作程序，不是吗？不过，关于黑手党，确实有杰克·鲁比这个人。我知道你说他没有参与有组织犯罪，但他绝对是有组织犯罪的边缘人物，我的意思是他在经营街头俱乐部，他一定是。是的，嗯，我知道他也否认他是任何阴谋的一部分，但如果他是，他会那样做，不是吗？在所有这些组织中，杰克·鲁比似乎最接近
to the mafia i suppose so yes i mean does that in any way possibly lend credibility to the theory? So you need to silence Lee Harvey Oswald. Why would you employ a nightclub owner from Dallas who wanders up a ramp in the one moment when the police are distracted, who seconds earlier has been in a queue at the Western Union sending money to a stripper. Maybe there's someone in the police involved. I mean, you know, this is what happens. And the Western Union to make sure that Ruby is... I accept that the moment you start tugging on a thread of, you know, the whole thing
黑手党，我想是的。我的意思是，这在任何方面可能为该理论增加可信度吗？所以你需要让李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德闭嘴。为什么要雇佣一个达拉斯的夜总会老板，他在警察分心的一瞬间走上坡道，几秒钟前他还在西联汇款排队给脱衣舞娘寄钱。也许警察里有人参与了。我的意思是，你知道，这就是发生的事情。还有西联汇款以确保鲁比是……我承认，当你开始拉动一根线时，你知道，整个事情
comes to pieces. And then, Tom, and then, right, you have to silence Oswald. Ruby, however, does not die. Ruby goes to prison. Well, he does in the long run. He dies in prison. Yeah, but everybody dies, Tom. I mean, this is the thing about the conspiracy theorists. They will point to witnesses
就分崩离析了。然后，汤姆，然后，对，你必须让奥斯瓦尔德闭嘴。然而，鲁比并没有死。鲁比进了监狱。嗯，他最终进了监狱。他在监狱里死了。是的，但每个人都会死，汤姆。我的意思是，这就是阴谋论者的问题。他们会指向证人
and they'll say, he died in 1982, he died in 1984, died in a car crash in 1967. Yeah, of course they all died. Everybody dies. All right, Mr. Cynic. All right, all right. So basically, none of those conspiracy theories you feel
他们会说，他死于1982年，他死于1984年，死于1967年的车祸。是的，当然他们都死了。每个人都会死。好吧，愤世嫉俗的先生。好吧，好吧。所以基本上，你觉得那些阴谋论没有一个
measures up, which then leaves the question, well, who did kill Kennedy? Who and why? And I think that we should finish this episode. And in our final episode of this immense epic sweep through the JFK assassination, we will look at your analysis of who was responsible for JFK's assassination and find out whether you agree with the Warren Commission. But if people simply cannot wait to find out the ultimate Dominic Sandbrook-approved solution to who killed JFK, you can, of course, join our chat community, as we love to call it. you can do that at therestishistory.com and we will welcome you with open arms however if you don't want to do that if you want to wallow in conspiracy theories and not have them all put to the sword then you'll have to wait till thursday but either way we will see you very soon. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
站得住脚，这就留下了一个问题，那么，到底是谁杀了肯尼迪？是谁，为什么？我想我们应该结束这一集了。在我们这次关于肯尼迪遇刺案的宏大史诗系列的最后一集中，我们将审视你对谁该为肯尼迪遇刺负责的分析，并看看你是否同意沃伦委员会的结论。但如果人们实在等不及想知道多米尼克·桑德布鲁克认可的关于谁杀了肯尼迪的最终答案，你当然可以加入我们的聊天社区，我们喜欢这样称呼它。你可以在therestishistory.com上这样做，我们会张开双臂欢迎你。然而，如果你不想这样做，如果你想沉溺于阴谋论而不愿让它们被一一驳倒，那么你将不得不等到周四。但无论如何，我们很快就会再见。非常感谢大家的收听。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。